there's a writer called henry wisemeyer
who wrote an essay called
the death of awe
in the age of awesome
he was talking about how we've lost
the connection to the sublime
feelings of such expansion that they
take
our breath away
he said
experience
is the new faith and we are refugees
from the mundane he was talking of
course
about a sensation of expansiveness known
as
awe
an experience of such perceptual
vastness
such perceptual expansion
that your mental models of the world
are obliterated in an act of ecstatic
accommodation and quaking annihilating
glory an experience
of awe
breaks you
open you experience a fresh
the hardly bearable ecstasy of direct
energy exploding on your nerve
endings goosebumps
overwhelm rockets take off into orbit
you
marvel at the stars you blast new
tunnels between the mind and the other
[Music]
like a space telescope
that mainlines space and time through
the optic nerve
you are compelled into aesthetic
contemplations face to face with
something can measure it to your
capacity
for wonder
you experience a fresh
hardly bearable ecstasy
direct energy
burning itself on your retinas the bliss
[ __ ] crucifixion whereas once i was
blind
now
i
can
see and these flashes of
revelation and these flashes of
revivification
they bring us back to life
the only dream i ever had was the
surface of the sun
every time i shut my eyes it's all i see
oh friends
you see we need
these transmutations we need
these revelations we need
these revivifications
and we need to marshal a response
[Music]
they should have sent a poet said
jodie foster in the movie contact when
witnessing a celestial event the birth
of a star
they should have sent
a poet
they should have sent a poet and as tim
duty said in these moments we
recontextualize the self we
see ourselves instead as a marvelous
conduit in a timeless hole
from which molecules
and meanings flow
oh
my goodness gracious oh
my mental models of the world oh
these obliterations oh
these transformations all these
riverfications like a modern-day charlie
mingus
i will riff and rhapsodize through a
tumbling thicket of impressions
with such a sharp and vital alacrity
that it will take my breath away
it will take my breath away
[Music]
friends you see
we are in search of the miraculous
we are in search of the bliss [ __ ]
crucifixion we are in search
of ecstatic revelations and we shall
spend our days and nights
uttering
ejaculations
of amazement
poetry
and grace
[Music]
[Laughter]
chicken
[Music]